AMORE!!BUON NATALE (HAHAAH) sei esaurita??sei schizzata?Buon Natale!!Ora levo il caffè!!
AMORE!!!! BUON NATALE!! (hahahahahah) sei esaurita?? (hahah) Perchè??? Sei schizzata??! Buon Natale!! (hahahah) Ora leva il cappello!!
ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti in questo nuovissimo VIDEOOO
Ciaoo a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti in questo nuovissimo VIDEOOOOO!!!
SONO qui con una persona molto speciale lo conoscete tutti
per chi non lo conoscesse
Sono qui con una persona molto speciale,lo conoscete tutti
è mio cugino(haha) Salvatore no scherzavo è il mio fidanzato.
Per chi non lo conoscesse è mio cugino,Salvatore (hahah) no scherzavo è il mio fidanzato.
gli volevo fare un piccolo scherzetto per metterlo in imbarazzo visto che lui odia che faccio video...ecc.ecc.
E gli volevo fare un piccolo scherzetto per metterlo in imbarazzo, visto che lui odia che gli faccia video ecc ecc...
quindi apprezzato lo sforzo e  la sua presenza oggi qui
Quindi apprezzate lo sforzo e la sua presenza qui oggi
no no non mi stai metttendo in imbarazzo
non importa
Non importa
abbiamo preparato in due ore questo mhusup
Abbiamo preparato in due questo Mash-up delle canzoni di natale
delle canzoni di natale
Non mi stai mettendo in imbarazzo
quindi speriamo tanto che vi piaccia; e speriamo tanto cheeee
apprezziate lo sforzo.
Quindi speriamo tanto che vi piaccia e speriamo tanto che apprezziate lo sforzo
insomma,c'è  io non sono una cantante e lui non è un musicista
Insomma io non sono una cantante e lui non è un musicista
ma ci siamo divertiti molto
allora non guardatelo
Ma ci siamo divertiti molto
e vabhe lo guardano
Allora non guardatelo (hahahahaha)
hahahahahahaha
Eh vabbè lo guardano (hahahahahahaha)
Vabbè se lo volete guardare guardatelo e fateci sapere se vi è piaciuto questo nostro Mash-up
eh...
(smack)
BUON NATALE!!!
A OK
E..... (Smack) Buon Natale!!!!